je heureux de revenir à à tour parce que
je je vais avoir au moins du du temps de
jeu on sait que là-bas c'était compliqué
euh voilà le changement d'entraîneur
c'était c'était compliqué et je savais
qu'en revenant ici j'allais avoir du
temps de jeu et je pense que voilà il
une opération maintien et et depuis
depuis décembre il y a eu l'équipe a
beaucoup souffert et maintenant voilà on
a ils sont réussi à sortir de de de
cette période difficile et voilà on a on
a la tête hors de l'eau et voilà j'ai
j'ai deux objectifs évidemment collectif
et un personnel maintenant je vais
essayer de remplir les deux et tu dis ça
fait fait de 3 mois que j'ai pas trop
joué j'ai été j'aiété sérieux en dehors
j'ai fait tout pour être prêt
physiquement je savais que il y allait
avoir une porte de sortie à wiigan et
donc voilà
maintenant je vais essayer de d'être
prêt le plus rapidement et voilà je
pense que avec l'envie que j'ai de de
revenir sur le terrain ça va rattraper
le manque physiquement